between the wild hunts the White Flame
and why everyone seems to want a piece
of Siri there are a lot of head
scratching moments in the first five
episodes of season three of The Witcher
Francesca lost a newborn daughter in
season two and that sets off a series of
catastrophic events for not only the
elves but for everyone who has come into
contact with them after a tentative
alliance with nilfgaard orchestrated by
frangela the elves were lulled into a
false sense of security only for
Devastation to ensue when her child was
killed this led Francesca to lushels and
kill several nilfgaardian children the
reveal that the nilfgaardian King series
father was a culprit in this horror
makes it all the more upsetting the
grief over her child is overwhelming and
it makes sense that Francesca's judgment
is completely compromised but no one
else seems to be making particularly
good decisions either Francesca's only
purpose now is Revenge but that's all
the more reason why her support system
should be stepping up and giving her
time to properly grieve we know that the
elves have had serious problems with
their leaders in the past so it's kind
of surprising that there aren't better
safe plays for taking care of her yet
the only attempts made to bring
Francesca back to her senses have been
either gentle coaxing or outright
betrayal both of these strategies have
made the situation drastically worse as
it is she's a mother who was lost not
just her child but the hope for a better
future for her people making her the
most dangerous kind of leader maybe it
isn't so much that elf history is
confusing just that we don't know all
that much about it and everything we
learn leaves us with more questions for
instance blood origin that the handiwork
of explaining a bit of context around
the conjunction of the Spheres and
events that saw worlds merge and
delivered an influx of humans and
monsters to the world even still we get
the feeling that the four episodes
spin-off only scratched the surface we
met some major players and saw the
beginning of the decline of the Elven
Empire but that's a far way away from
actually explaining the full history of
the elves when geralt was captured by
elves in the first season they're
hanging on by a thread after centuries
of anti-alph aggression and attacks in
season three we hear a bit more about
Elven history as Jennifer and Garrosh
tells Siri the tale of an ancient hero
even that Legend seems entirely open to
interpretation as Siri offers
counterpoints to Jennifer's narrative
when it comes to the elves we're getting
a lot of exposition in a very condensed
format but if you have questions about
what the elves have been up to since
well forever we're right there with you
considering that they didn't
particularly want to be bothered by
geralt or his friends to begin with Cod
ringer and Finn's entirely demise at the
hands of riens came as a bit of a shock
when reince arrives at the library it's
not clear what his true motives are for
torching the place and his occupants the
two researchers gave geralt only a
sparse amount of Intel during his visit
but it costs them their lives and we
can't help but feel it was a bit of an
escalation while it shows us that Ryans
is willing to resort to object cruelty
to accomplish his goals we kind of
already knew that we can't tell but feel
that these two have way more use alive
than dead please not the cat become
everything all of our confusion around
this one may be rooted in our love for
the lovably curmudgeonly Cod ringer and
fan their cat and their Stellar book
collection but there does still feel
like a bit of a waste Jennifer taking
Siri to aratuza makes a lot of sense
it's clearly a decision she struggled
with as does geralt but they agree
together to split up for the good of the
princess Jennifer takes her to train
with the best Mages on the planet while
geralt goes after riens who continues to
work in service for mysterious
benefactor this is a choice that you'll
struggle with particularly Jennifer who
knows that brotherhood's hypocrisy
embarks at the idea of taking Siri to
them despite her faith in their
inability to keep her safe though
yennefer explains her own history to
Siri she doesn't prepare geralt's
adopted daughter for how hard the Mages
are on their novices she also doesn't
fully explain the strange political
climate that made it such a struggle for
her to train there when Siri first meets
some of yennefer's fellow Mages she's
immediately treated like a servant she
bristles at this and though yennefer
explains to her that this is how you
play politics in the World of Magic it's
not enough to convince Siri who flees on
Horseback those series Brash flight from
the town is in character for her it
definitely exposes a lack of
understanding about the severity of her
situation
Jennifer's feelings towards to Sayer the
Brotherhood and aratuza are complex she
views to say of both as a mother figure
and friend while still acknowledging her
more severe personality traits life of
aratuza is what gave her power but she
suffered at the hands of her teachers
and fellow students finally the
Brotherhood has long served as a thorn
in her side due to its hubris and
unwillingness to change but she admires
her power and sees herself as one of
them even if she occasionally chafes at
the idea to say his fondness and pride
in yennefer are clear but she continues
to keep secrets from her pupil this is
certain to cause more harm to their
relationship meanwhile the Brotherhood
watched Jennifer are more
single-handedly in the Battle of sodden
Hill at the end of season 1. only to
more or less put her on trial in season
two in season 3 they're universally
annoyed by her presence but most of the
Mages ultimately see the benefits of a
plea to a more United Brotherhood by the
end of episode 5 it seems that she's
been invited back into the phone but
this is a pretty tempestuous bunch of
people so we'll have to wait and see
this is one that we can rest assured
that we'll find out more about it soon
but that doesn't change the fact that we
still have pretty much no clue what's
going on with Siri's dad the White Flame
of nilfgaard perhaps the biggest Swiss
of the second season was revealed that
he was alive at all with Siri believing
he and her mother Paris has seen many
years before more shockingly he's the
Emperor of nilfgaard meaning that he's
responsible for the damage we've seen
his invading Army Corps to the Northern
Territories in the novels a white flame
is fascinates him with his daughter's
Elder blood her lineage inspires him to
make choices that are some of the most
controversial plot points of the book
while the Netflix series has stayed
relatively true to the source material
and made a few major deviations last
season included in that there could be
more changes on the way at present all
we know of Emperor Emir is his glorified
tale of taking back his kingdom with the
power of his sword but he has a tendency
of being an unreliable narrator so we
have to take his claims with a grain of
salt the build up for the wild Hunt has
been extreme with blood origin diving
into the distant past in no small part
to introduce us to the leader of this
group of wraiths aerodynamos the captain
of the Centralia military makes several
bad moves in a very short period of time
drawing the lead into the conjunction of
the Spheres and to cost him first he
plans a coup with Balor then sides with
the Merwin in hopes of securing a better
future for himself and his lover Brian
he has ultimately Banished with several
of his men to an alternate Dimension
while we haven't seen much in the way of
his transformation to the leader of the
wild hunts we can guess the story isn't
a particularly cheery one though this
season has given us glimpses of the
awesome power of the hunt and we know
that their pursuit of Siri will continue
but still not sure what their ultimate
goal is it's hinted that series Power
could act as a key to unlock the barrier
between Realms but perhaps they want to
induct Siri into their group either way
we're still very much at the beginning
of their story
when we first met vilga forts he was
manipulating Jennifer to return to
aratuza to help him avoid being drafted
into service by the king of nilfgaard
after that we saw him slay a fellow Mage
during the Battle of sodden Hill this
created significant doubt about where
his loyalties lie while to Saya Caesar
good in him even that has become fairly
questionable at times particularly when
he lashed out at her during season two
having taken leadership of the
Brotherhood vilgafort seems calm through
the first few episodes of season three
he even charms Jennifer who has good
reason not to trust him using their
shared love for to say he wins Jennifer
over but to Watson just still and clear
though there are plenty of theories
swirling around him as of the fifth
episode and there might be a major blow
up on the horizon with Strega bore in
prison for hiding a bug that he denies
having taken we suspect that this could
have easily been planted in his room by
vilgafort
okay here has been a mysterious
character from the start he led the
invasion of sintra and attempted to
kidnap Siri he continues his pursuit of
Siri and in his search Massacre is a
group of Cintron refugees he continues
his Rampage by enlisting a Doppler to
kill Siri's childhood mentor malsak and
takes his form the Doppler tricks her
into trusting him but traumatizes her by
leveraging her only true friend against
her he later kills an entire Tavern of
people just to make sure none of the
people inside of the Doppler without a
doubt kahir is one of the most
terrifying characters in the series due
to his unsettling dedication to the
White Flame in season 2 he and yennefer
are forced to flee together after she
refuses to take his life on behalf of
the Brotherhood this sets off a chain of
events that sees him returning to
nilfgaard and allying himself with the
equally ruthless fringilla when she
murders several generals for treachery
but leaves kahira alive it becomes clear
that these two have some kind of
connection but is it just their
commitment to the White Flame we have
seen time and again that kahir will do
anything for the king of nilfgaard
virtual discovering that fringella is
still alive despite the White Flame clay
she has died change any of that for
someone who has appeared in so many
episodes we still don't know much about
what drives kahir so far we know very
little of Philippa making her a
confusing character we met her in season
two as an owl working in tandem with
Dykstra but as for what her specific
motivations are beyond the wild grub for
power we're still pretty clueless we've
seen her involved in s m with dijkstra
and engaging in an affair with one of
visamir's staff and we know she's
orchestrated more than one brutal murder
but we still don't know why one
fascinating tidbit that has been dropped
in the third season is that she and
tasaya had a falling out when Jennifer
asked to say what's happened the Mage
dismisses what happened as two friends
simply growing apart
nothing to understand
friendship just ran its course yet
Philippa seems to have plenty more to
say on the subject leaving us to wonder
what exactly went down between these two
powerful Mages and philippa's mystery
goes even deeper with her connection to
aratuza and her unique Mastery over
shape-shifting still mostly unexplained
at this point these plot threads could
go in just about any direction so we're
on the edge of our seeds with Philippa